do you believe that success is mostly
about hard work and talent or do you
think that mindset plays a bigger role
than most people realize when it comes
to billionaires the answer is clear
mindset is everything in this episode
we'll explore the fascinating world of
billionaire mindsets and how it can help
you achieve your own goals no matter how
big or small from Warren Buffett's moat
mentality to Richard Branson screw it
let's do it attitude we'll take a look
at the specific mindset traits and
strategies that have helped billionaires
build their Empires and leave a lasting
impact on the world we'll uncover the
power of curiosity the importance of
harmonizing your life and work and the
value of always being the student will
also reveal the surprising mindset
habits that billionaires use to stay
motivated focused and grounded even in
the midst of chaos and uncertainty so
whether you're an entrepreneur investor
or simply looking to learn from the best
this episode is for you get ready to
master your mindset unleash your full
potential and discover the secret to
billionaire success enjoy
thank you
okay let's take it off with secret
number one look for a moat with Warren
Buffett what we're trying to do is we're
trying to find a a business with a wide
and long-lasting mode around it
uh surrounded and protecting a terrific
economic Castle
with an honest Lord in charge of the
castle
and
in in essence that's what business is
all about I mean you may want to be the
lord of the castle yourself and in which
case uh
you don't worry about that last Factor
but what you're trying to what what
we're trying to find is a business
that for one reason or another it can be
it can be because it's the low-cost
producer in some area it can be because
it it has a natural
franchise because the service
capabilities it could be because of its
position in the consumer's mind it can
be because of a technological advantage
for any kind of reason at all
that it has this motor on it and then
our then what we have to decide is is is
all Mulcher are subject to attack in a
capitalistic system so everybody is
going to try if you've got a big castle
in there people are going to be trying
to figure out how to get to it
and what we have to decide and most most
aren't worth a damn and you know in
capitalism I mean that's the nature of
it and it's a constructive thing that
that's the case
but we are trying to figure out what is
keeping why is that castle
still standing
and what's going to keep it standing or
cause it not to be standing 5 10 20
years from now what are the key factors
and how permanent are they
how much do they depend on the genius of
the Lord in the in in the castle and and
then if we feel good about the moat
then we try to figure out whether
you know the lawyer is going to try and
take it all for himself
uh whether he's likely to do something
stupid with the proceeds Etc but that's
that's the way we
we look at businesses Charlie and I try
and distinguish between
businesses where
you have to been smart once
and businesses where you have to stay
smart
and I mean retailing is a good case of a
business where you have to stay smart
you can uh
you are under attack all the time people
are in your store if you're doing
something successful they're in your
store the next day trying to figure out
what it is about your success that they
can transplant and maybe add a little
something on uh in their own situation
so you cannot Coast
in retailing uh there are other
businesses where you only have to be
smart
once at least for a very long time there
was once a southern publisher
who was doing very well and with his
newspaper and and someone asked him the
secret of his success
and he said Monopoly and nepotism
and
I mean he wasn't so dumb I mean it he
didn't have any Illusions about himself
and and if if you had a big Network
of Television Affiliates station 30
years ago
there's still a major difference between
good management and bad management I
mean a major difference but you could be
a terrible manager
and and make a fortune basically because
the one decision to own the network
uh TV affiliate overcame
almost any deficiency
that existed from that point forward and
that would not be true
if you were the first one to come up
with some concept in retailing or
something of the sort I mean you would
have to be out there defending it every
day
uh ideally
you know is you want you want terrific
management at a terrific business and
that's what we we look for uh uh but as
we pointed out in the past if you have
to choose between the two get a terrific
Business secret number two is screw it
just do it with Richard Branson I've
always uh uh had the philosophy that's
you know screw it uh just do it is a lot
more fun than
um than not scary
um and um and sometimes it's got me into
a lot of trouble and sometimes more
often than not it's been it's been
fantastic and
um so you know I suppose one of my
greatest fear in life is saying no to
something and then regretting it so
um so I have said yes a lot and um and
in the case of um you know the learning
Adventures
um yeah the helicoster's my life but it
it helped put virgin on the map on a
global basis and
um and you know help help get the brand
established and
um and it was actually great fun when it
when it was going well and it was
actually terrifying when it wasn't it
was the first
um time that uh well five people had
actually tried to cross the Atlantic
five people that died so it was it was
the it was the attempt to try to do it
differently than the others had done it
and that was to fly in the jet stream at
35 000 feet where you've got very strong
winds to be above the bad weather
um and
um uh and you know we were the first and
then and then foolishly we decided to do
the Pacific
and a lot a lot of exciting things went
wrong on the way but we missed Los
Angeles I think by two and a half
thousand miles which is what we were
aiming for and ended up in the Arctic
but
um but they were they were great
adventures secret number three is
harmonize your life and work with Jeff
Bezos my view is I don't even like the
phrase
work-life balance I think it's
misleading I like the phrase work life
Harmony
because I know that if I am energized at
work happy at work feeling like I'm
adding value
um part of a team whatever energizes you
that makes me better at home it makes me
a better husband a better father and
likewise if I'm happy at home
it makes me a better employee a better
boss all the things it's not about it's
not primarily about there may be crunch
periods where it's about the number of
hours in the week but that that's not
the mo that's not the real thing usually
it's about do you have energy and is the
is your work depriving you of energy or
is your work generating energy for you
and you know there are people everybody
in this room knows people you who
fond of these two camps you're in a
meeting and the person comes in the room
some people come into the meeting and
they add energy to the meeting other
people come into the meeting and the
whole meeting just deflates and those
people just they they drain energy from
the meeting and you have to decide which
of those kinds of people you're going to
be are you going to add energy
um and the same thing at home and the
same thing at home and it's so it's a
wheel it's a psych it's a flywheel it's
a circle it's not a balance because a
balance that's why that metaphor is so
dangerous because it implies there's a
strict trade-off and um you could be out
of work have all the time for your
family in the world but really depressed
and demoralized about your work
situation and your family wouldn't want
to be anywhere near you they would wish
you would take a vacation from them and
so it's not about the number of hours
not primarily I suppose if you went
crazy with you know 100 hours a week or
something yeah that maybe maybe there
are limits and they probably I've never
had a problem
um and I think it's because both sides
of my life give me energy and and that's
what I would recommend that's what I do
recommend to interns and execs also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your special specific plan of action
to make sure you're getting results if
you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
secret number four is use physics
principles in your thinking with Elon
Musk and the way I tend to view problems
is from a from a physics standpoint and
I think I think physics is a good
analytical framework
um and one of the key things in in
physics is to reason from first
principles this is contrary to the way
most human reasoning takes place which
is by analogy
um
reason for first principles just means
that you figure out what are the
fundamentals what are the fundamental
truths or or things that are pretty
people are pretty sure are fundamental
truths and and can you build up to a
conclusion from that uh you know for
from those principles and
uh and then certainly if you come up
with some idea and it appears to violate
one of those fundamental truths then
you're probably wrong
um or you should get a really big prize
or something like that
um
so uh this may seem like I don't know it
maybe it may seem sort of obvious when
it's explained but it's actually not
what people do
um the reasoning by analogies is helpful
because it's a shortcut yeah
um and it's and it's mostly correct but
but uh it tends to be most incorrect
when you're dealing with new things
because it's hard to analogize to
something really new secret number five
is follow your curiosity with Mark Cuban
Michael Jordan had the body he had the
temperament of a champion so he goes
into sports do you think they call that
bounded rationality instead of saying I
could be every possible thing in the
world you kind of limit it and say all
right I'm more of a math guy oh more of
a people person and then you try to find
your destiny within that well I think
they go hand in hand right because the
type of person you are that you know
kind of points to the things you're good
at are you 12 you're not going to know
are you 16 you're not going to know if
you're 18 maybe if you have a special
talent yeah right you know you can throw
a baseball 100 miles an hour you can
sing and your voice is incredible you
know you're you're you know a concert
pianist you're a chess Grand Master if
you have a specific skill set or talent
that just immediately propels you to the
top yeah you want to follow that yeah
but I remember having a list I still
have it when I graduated from college I
was getting ready to graduate and all
the different industries that I thought
I might want to partake in when you find
something you're good at yeah go for it
yeah and I also also always say it's not
about passion everybody's got passion
for something yeah right don't follow
your passions follow your efforts
because people say you know I was
passionate to play baseball I was
passionate to play basketball it doesn't
mean all of a sudden I was going to be
good enough yeah but I found myself
spending being really curious about
business being really curious about
technology and that curiosity is really
what drove me and I think particularly
if you're young today curiosity is great
always learning and trying to find new
things being curious about new things
because that's what leads you to that
path trying to figure out in advance
yeah that's hard because you don't know
what you don't know secret number six is
become the best version of yourself with
Oprah when free I have paid attention to
my life because I understand that my
life just like your life is always
speaking to you where you are in the
language
with the people
but the circumstances and experiences
that you can understand and interpret if
you are willing to see
that always
life God is speaking to you
now
it took me a while to actually really
get this and to understand it but once I
did I started paying attention to
everything and one of the reasons why I
can now accept the fact that I can offer
my Gatherings of information and wisdom
and call myself a spiritual teacher
is that every single person who ever
came on my show and I hear there's like
37 000 guests I've talked to
a lot of them came from dysfunction and
a lot of them wouldn't appear to be
teachers but every one of them had
something to say that was meaningful and
valuable and that I could use to grow
myself
into the best of myself which is what
all of our jobs are your number one job
is to become more of yourself and to
grow yourself into the best of yourself
and secret number seven the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
always be a student with Bill Gates you
went to Harvard and you dropped out have
you ever thought how your life could be
better off if you had gotten your
Harvard degree
well I I'm a weird Dropout because I
take college courses all the time I love
uh Learning Company courses and and
things so I love being a student and
there were smart people around and you
know they fed you and they gave you
these nice grades that made you feel
smart uh so I I feel it was unfortunate
uh that I didn't get to stay there but I
don't think I missed any knowledge
because you know whatever I needed to
learn I would I was still in a a
learning mode
my dad did a style of martial arts
called Kyoko shinkai and um and I
suppose this little boy trying to get
close to that I was like well if he's
doing it I'm going to join him so my dad
and I shared this incredible passion of
martial arts and cars right
um
so I kind of get started you know with
my father then he gets gunned down when
I'm 13 years old and I went through like
a year of just nothing I just I couldn't
show up at the dojo I didn't have it in
me
and I did all the things we're talking
about the excuses at the time South
Africa had a a particularly high crime
problem and I was like you know what's
the point you know here's a first degree
black belt who gets attacked he get
takes nine bullets and he's dead anyway
why am I going to this thing called the
dojo right
again excuse is valid it really is
but there's no progress
so a year nothing
and then and then I was like I actually
miss it so I went back
it was interesting when I went back it
wasn't the same I wasn't doing the Qatar
to impress the senseis anymore
I was doing the Qatar because I wanted
every single movement
to be as close to Flawless as I could
get it
it changed my entire perspective so and
one of the things that happened you're
going to love this I'm literally getting
chills thinking about it one of the
things that happened is time
just expanded
so because we have a very finite
construct of time I'm going to be at the
dojo for an hour
but what happened was that hour felt
like five hours and sometimes 30 minutes
felt like five
all of a sudden this fixed construct of
time you know it started to change
because my relationship with what I was
doing changed so it wasn't just a punch
it wasn't just the cutter I wasn't just
I wasn't just showing up for the emotion
I was embedded in every single part of
the process I was looking for growth for
Progress right I have to tell you that
changed my entire life
so anytime I find myself stuck now
I recognize that often the reason I'm
stuck is because I'm focusing on the
output and I'm not focusing on my input
right so output I've got to raise 100
million Rand for my business output I've
got to get 300 growth for you know in
customers output I've got to get 25 yeah
that's all output
but what you got to focus on is input
what are the things I've got to do and
how do I do those things intentionally
deliberately and try to get better every
single time every meeting every impact
conversation with one of my staff
members every engagement with a client
or a potential client every single one
of those things how do I focus on that
moment because actually the output is a
sum total of how those things come about
so when you when you are at the dojo and
you are being graded and you are going
through the process of trying to attain
your black belt or your brown belt
that's what everybody sees is the output
but what actually went in was that
malleable construct of time where you're
trying to perfect every single movement
I am an extremely hard individual okay I
know what it takes to be in the position
I'm in it is not easy okay I have paid
attention for 30 years to everything
when it comes in and when it goes out
and where it goes and whether or not
this energy that came in or the energy I
put out hey does it actually pay me so
that I can produce a something in the
future okay anybody anybody can have
this much success in life
to string it together for 32 years never
have a bankruptcy never not pay a debt
never ever ever okay walk away from
something I didn't know it is very very
difficult
going out knocking on the door making
some money getting a sale great winning
a course in a case in court great okay
getting a degree to college good you can
do that okay anybody can do all that
stuff to string together 30 years
and be able to survive recessions okay I
am an extremely intelligent person when
it comes to money okay we're the most
resilient
people on the planet I mean except for
maybe persons
[Music]
I mean really persons are unbelievable
okay in the Roman Romans the Romans
okay but but you notice if you look at
those civilizations man Persian wrote
look there was a time when they had
everything they had it all and they lost
it because they started making mistakes
they started thinking oh well we'll go
on forever we don't have to be diligent
we don't have to pay attention we don't
have to do the right things okay you
were on a ship
[Music]
you're on the same ship I'm on okay I
own the ship but guess what it won't
matter it won't matter when the ship go
ship goes through rough orders hey your
stomach's gonna feel the same as mine
I'm not the only one that is scared in
these Waters I just know I ain't getting
off the ship
for you you actually could say and I'm
gonna get off I can't get off you
understand this is my show okay my
ship's gonna finish this trip I did 35
years of this I guarantee you I will die
on this ship okay and I will find other
places to go adventure and go other
places to have victories and other
civilizations to meet okay this is my
trip and if you want to be on it with me
for the whole ride you can be you can
get off anytime you want to probably
half of you will at some point get off
say I'm done here I got that man I will
pull into Port one day we'll drop the
what's that thing we'll drop the anchor
yeah
well hopefully you know you know when
the game walks the gang walk means we
push you off
hopefully you wait till we get to Port
and then you get off and then you walk
off into the village and you get uh some
some woman in the village pregnant and
you settle down there and you become a
new civilization whatever
what we used to do man it used to be
cool
okay can you imagine back in that time
hey new place let's go visit the people
hey are we going to be here in the
future well one thousand percent are we
gonna do another 10 extra conference
guaranteed
okay I mean if I'm not gonna do another
one of those I'm not doing it like I'm
done I need to go home get on a ship and
travel around and and not come back to
work anymore are we going to do are you
going to buy more real estate oh far 100
sure
so you're not going to stop this brand
and and the the the desired people have
and my mission is to help people
so and I cannot do this by myself every
one of you is needed okay but I need you
I need you right now to lean into this
thing
your job depends on what you do every
day your job depends on
okay not not your job with me your job
period on this planet
depends on how much you take your
shoulder and put it against the wheel
and push and get a product a product
okay for us this products are people
know about Grant Cardone people know
about our webinars people know about our
opportunities people know about our
books I need you to do more than your
job I'm already paying you to do your
job
okay you're not going to get a bonus if
you don't do more than your job I'm just
telling you
if he don't finish that movie
if the tickets don't sell Kevin Hart
will not get the bonus you have the MLB
baseball players for the Marlins they do
not get paid this year if there is no
season you understand that
they're like I'll get my check anyway
you didn't play bro
okay if I get hurt in the NFL and I
don't play I don't get paid that's the
real world
so when I get the when I hear the
numbers in the morning sometimes you
guys don't see me there because when I
hear we got a hundred licenses I'm like
God damn we should have ten thousand and
everybody in this room should have sold
one and got a commission on it
so again if you don't like if you're in
shipping Sherry told me somebody in
shipping them like why is that person in
shipping when's that person how can that
person live on 16 an hour
or 20 an hour we took them down for 20.
how can you live on twenty dollars an
hour
in Miami
okay I'm not going to pay any more for
the position
how can you make sense of it I don't I
don't understand that like
there's all this other stuff we have to
sell man everybody every time I meet
somebody coming to my boot camp coming
to my webinar you coming you got a book
you got this program you got a wristband
okay how about a t-shirt
like like every time I talk to somebody
I'm like once you grab one of my things
because I know that drives a little bit
of Exchange
once he gives me money he has a
relationship with me
the moment he gives me money we actually
complete the relationship it is only
then okay you guys that are on Natalie's
team you can call and talk to these
people and help them as much as you want
you're not actually having a
relationship when you do this help
when they exchange back with you you
complete the health cycle okay they have
to give you something for the help
otherwise it's a handout
and nobody wants to handle
except people that have given up
and lost self-respect of themselves
nobody wants a handout they want a
little hey come on you know but nobody
they'll resent me if I keep giving them
a so remember when they say hey
I want something great make sure they
give you something back
okay so so that we can complete that
relationship or start one and we can
start actually doing business with one
another in that year when I was really
broke and I was really broken I was
working at La Unified School District
foreign
I was miserable
I was miserable because I wasn't living
in my dream I was just doing a j-o-b and
then one day
I said well what what do I need to do I
I need to I need to buy my freedom
that's what I need to do I need to buy
my freedom well I don't know about
buying my freedom I don't know about
buying I don't know about having money
saved up my family didn't have money
saved up my mother used to tell me oh
this money is burned in my pocket so I
know two things about money it's hot
and we can't keep it long
we'd always have one week where we had
all the food in the refrigerator and
then one week where we were the
refrigerator was empty
right come on come on some of you guys
know about that to this day I spend so
much money on groceries you guys oh my
God it's like I'm feeding like a family
of 10. because I'm so afraid of anybody
ever being in my house and being hungry
and so I I wrote a check to myself
Jelani was three
110 dollars
I took it to the bank
Wells Fargo
started a new account
the next check I wrote
125 dollars
and just like the first check I put in
the memo line funding my dream I wasn't
even clear what the dream was
but I knew there was something in my
belly who in this room know you got
something in your belly it's something
I'm not even clear about it I don't know
how clear you are but I wasn't clear
about it but I knew there was a calling
on my life greater than working for La
Unified School District no disrespect to
La Unified School District it just
wasn't my destiny
I wrote another check in two weeks
146 dollars
funding my dream
now I started mailing the checks in
because I didn't want to see my balance
because I didn't want to go shopping
because I you're gonna repeat what you
learn right until you decide to not
repeat what you've learned
so I mailed the check in and I wrote
another check and I wrote another check
and every check I wrote I made sure it
was five percent more than the first
check the net the previous check I sold
my Altima I had a car note sold my
Autobook bought a clunker because it
didn't have a car note now I can write a
bigger check funding my dream
I moved out of my three bedroom three
bath three bath house and moved in
became a roommate with my friend who
smoked I put towels at the base of the
door so the smoke wouldn't come to the
door I was willing to be inconvenienced
are you yes yes I'm just saying I'm just
I'm just showing you the story I just
the charge I just gave you I stopped
getting my hair done that was when I
started going natural
I I stopped going out I I stopped going
out dancing I stopped going out to
dinners my family didn't know what was
going on they thought oh my God you know
it's La she's on drugs but she's not
losing weight so maybe not I don't know
what's going on
I kept writing bigger checks to myself
nine hundred dollars nine hundred
dollars
I mailed it to Wells Fargo funding my
dream
eleven hundred dollars
mailed it to Wells Fargo funding my
dream I still wasn't clear what the
dream was
I just knew I had one
and it was being born through me
and I needed to give it a chance
that's all I knew
you don't have to see 2 000 feet in
front of you just see 200.
and run to the 200.
you'll have to see it all
three and a half years later I'd written
a check to myself every two weeks for
three and a half years
I didn't go out for three and a half
years I didn't go dancing I didn't get
my hair done I didn't get my nails done
for three and a half years are you
willing to be inconvenienced for your
conviction
I walk in to Wells Fargo three and a
half years later
and I said hi God bless you hi
my name is Lisa Nichols she was oh my
gosh you're the funding my dream lady
I was like
yeah I guess I am and all of a sudden
all the tellers came running around the
manager came they're like oh my God okay
oh my God we have been wondering we all
got the same question y'all know what
the question is right
what's your dream
I was like
um
I'm not sure
but I know that it includes inspiring
people
having people believe in themselves
again
teaching them how to get back up when
they've been knocked down
having to be willing to give themselves
a thousand Second Chances
and every time they get to 9.99 press
reset
I'm not sure what it's going to look
like but it's just going to help people
I said I came to check my balance I've
been writing a few checks to you guys
that say yes you've been writing a lot
I said I just want to check my balances
you don't know your balance I said no I
got this really big stack of summary
bank statements at home because my mama
said money Burns her pocket and I don't
want it to burn my pocket I wanted to
pay for my freedom
I said I just came to see what my
balance was if I had enough to fund my
dream as it gets clear
she wrote it down everyone's excited she
wrote it down turned it around to me I
looked at it I said oh no my name is
Lisa Shantae Nichols and my social
security number I said that is not my
money and I am not taking that money
because you're probably gonna want it
back
so just fix that error right now
and they looked at me
I said you really don't think that's
yours
I said no my family's never had five
thousand dollars in the bank or ten
thousand dollars in the bank
that's
sixty two thousand five hundred dollars
in the bank
they said Miss Nichols and everyone
teared up the manager teared up the
tellers teared up
they said Miss Nichols whatever your
dream is
I think you can fund it now
I looked at my son Jelani who now was
five or six and I said Jelani
our lives are going to be a little
different now baby
Jelani said yeah
Mommy can we
can't we now go to McDonald's
see for three years I've been telling
you Lonnie I'll make you a Big Mac
Mama makes Big Macs better than
McDonald's
and so it began with a hundred and ten
dollar check
so I don't know what yours is I don't
know what your radical looks like
for some of you your radical was coming
here
right yes yes and this is the beginning
this is the beginning of your radical
this is the this is the bet the next
best step this is the first step and so
I just stopped by to let you know you're
on the right path
and as you ramp up as you ramp up you're
going to have questions you're going to
be afraid I do more things afraid now
than I do Fearless
because the bigger you play the bigger
your breakdown
every single one of my errors in the
last five years have cost me six figures
like every single one every single one
of my errors has required me to call an
attorney
like they're just big because I'm
playing big
I'm playing big so be willing to go to
the edge
and this is where you are here
be willing
to go to the edge
and not just lean over
and feel the breeze
and watch the people jump
and watch them soar and look through the
windows at all the people who are living
great life don't just go to the edge and
feel it
be willing to lean
fill your heartbeat
feel it that lets you know you're alive
to let you know you're okay fear fuels
you fear lets you know go get more
information fear let you know step a
little later and study fear let you know
get up a little earlier fear let you
know ask for help fear is informing you
it's not stopping you it's just another
emotion like love and compassion and
gratitude we just made it paralyze us
see fear doesn't stop me fear informs me
and when you get intimately connected
with the fear I feel it and I'm moving
forward anyway I feel it and I'm gonna
love anyway I feel it and I'm going to
invest in me anyway I feel it and I'm
gonna show up and play anyway when you
get connected with fear it becomes your
best friend and when you stand on the
edge
you feel the breeze
you feel the fear
and you leap anyway let's say you have a
fear of public speaking is it really a
fear of public speaking that you have or
is it a fear of getting up on stage and
being embarrassed ashamed ridiculed or
judged
hmm let me take you to another type of
fear being buried alive can you imagine
for just a moment if there was an
earthquake or there was a natural
disaster and somehow you were buried
alive
wouldn't that trigger this crazy amount
of fear of dying while you were buried
alive now why am I taking you there I'm
taking you there because fear is a
subconscious trigger
whenever we feel threatened and the
threat could be a threat for our very
lives and when that happens we move into
one of four modalities and modality
number one is we try to fight this
feeling number two is we freeze because
we're in such shock number three we may
faint because of the neurochemistry that
the fear causes or we might run away if
we can run away now these neurological
reactions are our brain's way of keeping
us safe which is the highest need and
desire of the brain safety above all
else so when we are looking to achieve a
goal that we want to achieve and it
doesn't matter if it's you know to start
a business or grow your business or
leave a relationship that you're not
happy in or a job that you're miserable
in
whenever we think about the actual
behavior that is required to achieve
that goal
once we get motivated in doing that
that's part one of how our brain works
but right after that our brain has to
analyze if there's any real or imagined
danger associated with taking that
action step so if you are going to leave
a relationship that you're not happy in
your brain is going to activate the
memory circuits and discover what's in
there that may have caused you pain and
suffering in the past and when that
happens whether it's a relationship you
want to leave a job that you want to
leave a goal you want to achieve your
brain is always analyzing is there any
danger here and when there is real or
imagined Danger
the amygdala part of the brain the
emotional response Center in the brain
is going to fire off an amazing amount
of neurochemicals like cortisol
epinephrine or norepinephrine and it's
that Rush of those neurochemicals that
causes this emotion energy in motion we
label as fear now once you have that
Rush of neurochemicals in your
bloodstream that actually gives you an
enormous amount of energy
but what most people never have learned
how to do is how to take that energy and
channel it to action versus the fighting
it freezing or running away when you
recognize a fear I want you to do this
it's called inner size number one it's
called take six calm the circuits when
fear neurochemicals are released in your
brain you've activated the fear or
stress response Center in the brain when
you just observe
the emotion called fear through being
quiet and breathing six times in through
your nose and out through your mouth
like this you take a deep breath in for
five seconds
[Music]
foreign
you blow out like you're blowing out
through a straw and if you do this five
seconds in five seconds out five seconds
in five seconds out with six to ten
breaths
you're gonna deactivate the fear
response Center and that actually is
going to reactivate your thinking Center
in your brain so that you can move on to
Inner size number two inner size number
one is take six calm the circuits inner
size number two is called Aya a i a and
that stands for awareness intention
action so here's how you do this after
you do the first inner size then you
move to Inner size number two and then
you ask yourself in a calm relaxed state
what am I thinking right now what am I
feeling right now am I calm or am I
tense am I breathing deeply or shallow
is my heartbeat fast or slow and in this
state of calm awareness
as you deactivate the brain's fear or
stress response you can observe
what you are feeling and what you are
thinking and what you were doing and
then you can ask yourself the next
question that is the I what is my
intention right now is my intention to
move forward or is my intention to stay
in this fearful State and chances are
you gonna say well I really want to move
forward
and then you ask yourself what is one
action step that I can take
to move forward towards my goal and
dream so this is how it works after you
do the inner size number one
to calm the circuits and to deactivate
the reactive state that fear causes and
then you move into the second inner size
called Aya to move into the responsive
state
awareness intention action now puts you
in control of being aware of the fear
being aware okay of what you've been
thinking and then being at choice of
what you want to do so when you combine
these two inner sizes you are now
reconfiguring the neural network in your
brain around the goal that you want to
achieve and instead of allowing the real
or imagined danger to control you and to
stop you dead on your tracks you take
one action step in a calm State and that
rewires your brain so that the same
reaction doesn't hold you back anymore
and that you are now able to use fear as
your fuel for Success what is Max out
really stand for for you and when did
that moment happen where you knew that
that was gonna be part of your brand
yeah
um my son's name is Max so that helped
um but maxed out to me means this as you
know your obsessions become your
possessions whatever you end up being
obsessed with you'll eventually possess
so if you're obsessed with what you're
worried about your fears your problems
you're going to possess those and so I
became obsessed
um though the short version is is that
you don't know this I don't talk about
this on camera very much when I was 30
my uncle died at 50 years old
and he was the guy in my family we all
have this that you kind of resemble or
remind everybody of my dad's brother he
died at 50. sorry no thank you I
appreciate that it's a long time ago now
and um but he was kind of was my
godfather and or my culture that's a big
deal of course might as well yeah I know
shout out to Uncle Mike yeah mine was
Uncle Mike
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa everywhere
right there whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
Whoa man that's how the universe works
right
wow okay
you got me right there so mine was my
Uncle Mike
wow and oh man that just touched me
so
mine was my Uncle Mike and uh that blows
my mind right there brother
so
I'm on I'm at his funeral we're flying
back on the flight there's this thing in
your brain called the reticular
activating system it basically filters
into your awareness what's important to
you that's why like if you buy a new car
all of a sudden you see that car
everywhere on the freeway three lanes
over on the other side boom another one
they were always there why do you see
him now filtered into your importance
and heart attacks were at my he had died
of a heart attack and so I'm on the
airplane and I'm listening to music and
on the streams the Oprah show but I'm
it's in my awareness and it's a heart on
the screen I'm like
unplug my headphones plug it into the
phone system and it was about a new
heart scan that was happening at Cedar
signing where they could like it's
common now but they could not evasively
look at your heart and your arteries
long story short I hear it and I told my
wife I said schedule me for one of those
exams she's like it's expensive I said I
don't care schedule it we call it's a
nine month wait I go I need to get in I
need to get in I keep calling the lady
finally she goes there's a cancellation
tomorrow at two I go I'll be there so I
go down for the scan and thank God this
doctor understood influence and leverage
do you do the scan then you come back
after lunch I literally went ate a
burrito
came back I wasn't in shape I'm 30 years
old the doctor comes out and he goes um
no I'm looking for Edward mylet I go
it's mylet you know and he goes uh he
knew and he goes
well I can't believe these arteries are
in that younger body wow you need to
come back son
now my heart's racing I'm like what the
hell's in the skin we sit down instead
of what a normal doctor would do they
just go hey um here's the prescription
take Crestor work out eat goodbye he
understood reasons is what changes
people's lives massive reasons not
disciplined reasons and habits right
because let me ask you a question your
wife's beautiful
um do you have kids I go yeah I go I got
a son he's one he goes That's great um
do you want to be there when he
graduates high school
I went what he goes do you want to be
there when he graduates high school I
said uh yeah he goes okay uh you know
she pregnant huh I go yeah what does she
have and I said a girl you get to a dad
this is what you say he goes would you
like to walk that little girl down the
aisle on her wedding day son
I went what what is in this scan dude
and he goes I want to be very clear with
you young man I remember this like
yesterday because I want to be very
clear with you young man
if you continue down the road you're
going another man's going to live with
your beautiful wife and your mansion
walk your son at graduation and he's
going to be arm and arm with your
daughter on her wedding day not you
you'll be long gone actually as I tell
you this right now dude right and he
goes what I'm going to get you to do is
I'm going to get you to max out your
life and your Fitness
and I went
give me it yeah and he gave me exactly
what I needed to do and he said if you
do this you'll walk her down the aisle
blah blah blah from that day when I get
up like I did this morning and I'm tired
and I was late last night and I don't
want to go to the gym I swear to you
brother I swear to you I go Bella's
wedding get your ass up and I go I I'm
fit because I have massive reasons
that's why I'm fit and that started the
journey towards maxing out every area of
my life I'm like if I can do this in my
fitness I can do this in business I can
do this in my spirituality and
everything I'm not going to shortchange
myself by pretty good I'm going to see
what my real potential is what my
maximum capacity is every single day
because at the end of my life when I do
die I have this belief that when I'm
done the Lord's going to go well done
good and faithful servant and by the way
here's the man you could have been this
is the man you were born to be this is
the man you were destined to be this is
where you could have gone but you could
have seen the memories you could have
had the people you could help the person
you could have become and meet him my
obsession is that every day I'm chasing
that dude so that when I do die we meet
we're identical twins because the bad
end of a life whether it would be at 30
50 or 150 would be I meet that guy and
we're total strangers yeah so I'm
obsessed with meeting that guy someday
and that's what maxing out means it's
never too late to get started it's never
too late to say yes it's never too late
to start to chase down your dreams the
thing that you got inside you it's never
too late we create these stories for
ourselves as I am too old to get started
I am to acts like fill in a blank of
whatever excuse you've got for not
taking action
[Music]
it's just a story
you're just afraid and the only thing
you're missing is momentum
it's never too late
I remember when I started my business I
thought I was too young you know
I was 19 years old I was selling to
people who
were experts in science and I sucked at
science and they were two to three times
my age and I had phds and I thought I
was too young they'd never take me
seriously and that was one of the things
that really held back the growth of my
business was
just my limited belief that I was too
young
and I talked to people all the time and
you have people who say they're too
young
and then instantly they become too old
like but when are you over the right age
you know you're too young to do it then
you're too old to do it when were you
actually ever the right age when have
you ever said you know what I'm the
right age to do this thing
right we never we never do that it's
always just the fear talking
and so you have to step up you have to
step out you have to say yes
and you have to get started people ask
me all the time is it too late to get
started on YouTube I was at a conference
I was speaking at this weekend and
is it too late Evan is it too did I miss
the boat
kidding me
first off YouTube is growing like crazy
second the the education on YouTube is
still pretty low there's so many people
going and there's still so few people
who are creating good quality education
look at whatever field you're with is
probably even less
and third even if YouTube does go away
at some point
there's gonna be something else
people's attention is not going offline
anytime soon it's only going to increase
if YouTube goes away something else will
will come up and your ability to speak a
message to a camera is a skill set that
will serve you for life of course it's
not too late
it's just your fear talking
go up Big Dreams and big goals and big
Ambitions are possible
there's so few worlds where it actually
is too late right and like if you're 70
years old and you want to play you know
in the NBA Athletics is the easy one to
go to then that's it's too late you know
you're not going to go you're not going
to be a professional NBA player sorry
but could you be involved in the world
of could you start a great podcast
around it a YouTube channel around it or
be an agent or like infinite number of
things in that world of course and
chances are most of your goals dreams
things that you want to do
are not tied to anything physical where
there's going to be a significant
decline right like what are the things
what do you want to do what are your
goals it's people who have done it at a
much older age than you
so how do we unlock it how do we start
to make
that momentum actually happen in your
life step number one
get really clear on what you want
what do you want what are your goals
what do you what do you want to do
what's the voice inside your head that
is telling you I wish I could do this
thing I really want to do this thing
right like getting really clear because
I meet a lot of entrepreneurs and you
know that you're capable of more and you
know you want to have a bigger impact
and you know that
that you don't want to stay stuck here
but you don't know what the thing looks
like you know it's not as clear of what
you want to do you just know that you're
stuck and you're capable of more
well you definitely don't have the whole
thing planned out but what's the next
step
just getting clear on what you want the
next step to be
can make a big big big big big big big
difference
because it gives you some clarity
whether it's even the perfect I mean
it's not going to be the perfect step
don't worry about being the perfect step
it probably won't be the right the right
step it's a step
and in taking a step you learn a lot and
you make a lot of mistakes you make a
ton of mistakes and you figure things
out I remember when I first got my phone
I was recording and I I did this video
and I was I was so proud of the video
and then I realized I captured the whole
thing in slow motion mode
the audio was terrible you can't use it
I couldn't use it like oh it was so good
slow motion mode you just you're gonna
make mistakes at the beginning that's
okay but what's the next step getting
some clarity over what that next step
should be is really important part two
is then go get some Heroes
it could be a mentor who you can
actually talk to and learn from but
Heroes
and when I say Heroes I mean people
who've done the thing that you want to
do
whenever I feel less than whenever I
feel like I can't do it whenever I feel
not good enough I Look to people who
have done it
and I realized that they have done it
with less resources less money less time
less
skills and what I have right now Your
Heroes the people who you love look up
to respect the most they did it they
accomplished with less than what you
have right now
and if they can do it you can do it too
and the whole point of that is a push to
start taking action it's not to say oh
well I suck I can never be Oprah Winfrey
or whoever go look at Oprah's story and
see where she came from and see how how
poor she was and see what her upbringing
was and imagine being Oprah imagine
having a terrible upbringing uh you know
being raped early on having tons of
violence in the family
bouncing from home to home
being so poor that she couldn't afford
clothes and her grandmother would so
address for her out of a potato bag like
imagine you're going to school in a
potato bag
that your grandmother sewed together
because you didn't have enough money to
actually get real close
can you imagine
how bad is your life compared to that
how bad was your upbringing compared to
that
right to go from where she started to
where she's at
what's your excuse
and again it's not meant to be a
negative like oh you're right I'm so
hard on myself I suck no it's more like
well that's what's possible
as soon as you get over the store you're
telling yourself that's what's possible
she could do it
from that upbringing why can't you why
can't I
and anytime I feel like I can't do it
that that's what I default back to it's
like look at your Heroes look at where
they started look at where they came
from and chances are Your Heroes already
started with less than what you already
have right now and so surrounding
yourself with them
can give you the hope and the feeling
like it is possible if you feel like
you're too old for something then
surround yourself with entrepreneurs who
started who are way older than you
look at people who have started and they
started I don't know how old you are you
know people say I I'm 24 years old is it
too late to get started
but on every age people feel it's too
late
so surround yourself with the stories of
people who started when they're older
gives you the inspiration to go to make
to create
Island number three is come back to
service think about service think about
who you're doing this for this is this
is bigger than you it's not just about
you
so who are you going to help
whenever it's just about you whenever
it's you're doing something for just
selfish reasons
you'll never put in the same amount of
work as if you feel like you're
responsible to somebody else this is
where a lot of entrepreneurs struggle in
starting their own business because when
you had a job you had a boss and your
boss would tell you what to do if you
didn't show up to a meeting you'd be in
trouble you know so you'd show up for
other people but you don't show up for
yourself
we just won't show up for ourselves as
much people show up for other people so
the way to hack it is to feel like what
you're doing is actually serving other
people
and if you're an entrepreneur land you
can think about the customers you're
going to serve the people who will
consume your content or buy your
products or service and the life
changing impact that you're going to
have and feel it and connect to that if
you don't have a business yet or that's
not your ambition just think about your
message to your kids
think about the message to your family
think about the message to the people
around you is your message to your kids
current or future
you know what it's too late
you when you get an idea just tell
yourself that you can't do it
you know is that going to be your
message to your of course not
but it's your message to yourself
and the people closest to you will model
much more what you do
your actions your beliefs more than what
you say
you could tell them believe in yourself
you're not it's not too late go ahead go
do it you can make this happen but when
they see you sitting on the sidelines
telling yourself that you're too old and
you can't do it that's the behavior
they're going to model
so if you're not going to do it for
yourself
that's not enough of a oomph to get you
out of the bed and actually creating
your thing then think about who you're
serving today
think about the people you're going to
help
people who by you showing up is going to
have an impact on their lives
it's not too late to start
it's never too late to start
your life
could be so different
if you woke up and started doing a thing
that was in your heart it's not going to
work out at the beginning you're going
to have a lot of failures you're going
to have a lot of laughs you're going to
have a lot of struggles as you get going
but holy cow your life can be
dramatically different one year two
years five years from today
if you just decided you know what
I'm just tired of staying stuck
I'm tired of coming up with excuses
I'm tired of playing small
it's time
I need this for myself
I need this for my family
I need this for the people who I'm going
to serve and help
it's time
time
it's your time
let's see what you can make five grand
is a doable deal how do I do it it's 412
dollars a month
okay I gotta go steal the money I can
steal five thousand you could steal five
grand for me and I wouldn't even know
it's gonna be like if you could add five
thousand to that and earn twenty percent
it'd be worth a million 125. if you
could do this at ten percent it'd be
worth 320. some of you small thinkers
out there be like dude I'll take the
320. how do I get 10 and how do I get
20. you guys have figured this out
you're like
if the play is big enough dude I'll
figure that out everybody agree see what
I just I shifted your mind by giving you
a Target
I don't go to Target I get targets and I
keep targets and I refresh the Target
and the target is I want to be a
millionaire but over the period of time
I got 20 years by the way what would pay
me 20 a year over 20 years
and that is when your boy GC
got rich
I didn't get rich speaking I didn't get
rich selling books
I got rich shopping real estate
30 years old shopping every weekend dude
every weekend all I did between 25 and
30 years old was make money make money
make money and push it aside push it
aside push it aside even when in the
first years when I was not watch this
even when I was not
25 years old five grand boom next year
five grand
boom next year five grand boom guess
what next year oh by the way this
money's sitting dead in the bank
it's not not only anything it's it's in
a it's in a holy account
holy means okay I'm gonna put a hole in
your face if you're touching my money
nobody could get this money this is not
like sacred account okay you with me 28
oh wow man I could add a little bit
maybe there's more money 29. what am I
doing right here okay one two three four
boom I got 25 000 sitting in an account
it wasn't a million dollars and I'm five
years into the plan
but when I was ready to start investing
money I started doing my homework 30
years old
homework
shopping properties 31 homework shopping
properties 32. I'm not buying cars you
guys are buying cars flying on jet
Charters showing off going on vacations
all I'm doing is stacking paper
guess what happens I have five years of
putting five grand away next thing you
know I had twenty five thousand dollars
to add to my twenty five thousand
dollars next year I'm making more money
I got twenty five thousand dollars you
see what I'm doing I'm stacking dough
and looking for twenty percent
I know there's a 20 play out there some
of this money was sitting in the bank
this is years and years ago where the
bank would pay me six or seven or eight
it didn't matter that's not the target
the target is to get to 1 million
remember this and let's open up the
calls okay your job is to find a vehicle
that can pay you 20 a year might be a
business might be the business you're in
it might be to buy advertising for the
business or brand you're in for me it
was this I'm going to buy real estate
that over long periods of time I will
earn cash flow okay it's how the real
estate works
I put twenty five thousand dollars in a
deal
that deal is probably going to pay me 10
percent a year
you said yeah but Grant you said what'd
you say Grant would you say
20 grand that's what you said yeah I
know what I said
this ain't Eddie okay now how much do I
have I can reinvest that money back in
the deal the next year I have 27 000
five hundred dollars
[Music]
I earn 10 on that
that's 27.50 or something like that
I reinvest that now I got 30 000 in the
deal
okay but what you don't know is the the
rent on this property as I own it over
20 years
2038 will dispose of this thing the rent
is going up as I'm adding money the
rent's going up and maybe this goes from
10 percent a year
by the time I sell I want to be at 20
okay my average deal has paid me over 30
percent a year
[Music]
so when you start taking money and start
compounding it like that for long
periods of time the trick is long
periods of time the tax department which
every country has taxes determined they
want to know what kind of income do you
work for
So when you say to someone your age or a
child to the parent a parent parent to
the child
they say it's go to school get a job
they're working for this type of income
earned income
as you can see from this diagram here
this is earned income here and the first
thing you pay is the highest taxes
because you worked for money
yes the government doesn't want you
working for money they punish you for
that they want you to hire employees or
invest
okay so earned income is what they work
for the second
is portfolio income it's also called
capital gains so if I buy a house for
let's say a hundred thousand I sell it
for two hundred thousand the hundred
thousand is capital gains if I buy a
stock for ten dollars and sell it for
twenty the ten dollars of the capital
gains this is the second highest tax so
the tax breaks that President Trump is
working on today is primarily for these
guys here
so there are doctors lawyers
Highly Educated people and they have
stocks
most of these guys don't have stocks of
the working class they have a 401k
but they don't get the break
but these guys if you're active in
stocks and that kind of stuff of
flipping houses you gotta break but with
the really which work for
is
passive income and passive income
[Applause]
for me I have a business whether I work
or not money comes in
and you've seen me I'm not here am I no
I never never
I've earned the right not to be here
real estate I get millions every year my
wife and I can we add more real estate
also we have commodity income from oil
wells and things like this even the
stock price of oil doesn't go up and
down and all this we still look at this
but this is another type of income
this here a while I'll get into is
called Phantom income it's taxes I don't
pay so there's a little bit beyond most
people's minds but let's say my tax bill
is a hundred thousand dollars
by doing what the government wants here
the government may give me a fifty
thousand dollar tax break that means 50
000 in taxes I don't have to pay
[Music]
so the fifty thousand dollars it didn't
go to the government it went back up
here
so that's what Financial education does
it teaches you about the financial
statement which is not taught in school
again they teach you FICO scores which
is really fight those scores
was you told Lil Dougie
okay
and then for you at your age now you
want to know this this is what they're
teaching to work for now ironically
when you save money Ava 401k
this is the kind of income so Savings in
401ks are taxed the highest types of
income
to me it's stupid but if you don't know
any better is the saving money in
what he called it 401 cases good okay in
this in Canada it's called rrsp in
Australia called the superannuation
but
this is what most people
have because they went to school they
got a job
and then this is what the rich really
have it's passive
and it's because
I'm an active investor I don't buy this
because this is passive investors I am
active and I'm professional in all of
these areas
so I work for passive income which means
I'm not here
the check comes in the checks come in
every year and you've seen Kim and I and
your mother now
she's working on here and so your
mother's income keeps going up your
father's income keeps going up and they
don't have a job
[Music]
it's funny video I want to celebrate you
most people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome to learn the 10 skills that are
hard to learn but will pay off forever
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there so to help you on
your journey today I'm doing a video on
the 10 skills that are hard to learn but
will pay off forever and as always guys
if you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you